[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con los juegos
olímpicos de tokio que serán inaugurados
en dos semanas no tendrán espectadores
así lo anunciaron las autoridades
niponas que explicaron que la medida es
necesaria ante un nuevo aumento de casos
de kobe 19 el primer ministro yoshihiko
declaró el cuarto estado de emergencia
en la capital desde el inicio de la
pandemia a partir del 12 de julio y
hasta el 22 de agosto para hablar sobre
el tema saludamos a juan josé buscalia
periodista y comentarista deportivo
juanjo sea bienvenido a france24 y
comienza preguntándole cómo puede
afectar esta decisión el ánimo de los
atletas durante las justas buenos dias
angela y sin lugar a dudas que los
atletas sobre todo en el caso de locos
olímpicos en muchos casos en muchos
casos son atletas amateurs e impacta
mucho en el ánimo de los deportistas
aunque está esta competencia
específicamente la de los juegos
olímpicos de tokio que ya viene por
vuelta de un año
ha sufrido muchísimos embates porque se
va a celebrar en medio de la pandemia yo
digo que más allá del ánimo de los
deportistas también eso tendrá un
directo impacto en las arcas del comité
olímpico internacional recién escuchaba
que hablaban por ejemplo de copa américa
que se ha jugado íntegramente a puertas
cerradas esto significó que se dejen de
facturar 35 millones de dólares por
venta de tickets imagínense en un
olímpico en donde las competencias son
multiplataforma y donde hay acceso a un
montón de micro estadios que están
preparados para recibir público y que
ahora están con la expectativa de que
tenga que ser plenamente acuerdo cerrado
bueno y entonces a propósito de eso qué
va a pasar con quienes compraron
tiquetes de entradas a los escenarios
deportivos y que ya no pueden asistir
bueno es lo que están en estos momentos
definiendo las autoridades
gubernamentales en tokio porque lo que
si ya está definido es que no habrá
venta de tickets para la ceremonia
inaugural pero para el resto de los días
recordemos estamos hoy exactamente a 14
días de comienzo de los juegos
para el resto de los días todavía no
está terminado de decidir si es que no
se va a permitir que haya público
después de las nueve de la noche hay
muchas competencias que terminan ya muy
cerca de la medianoche en tokio muchas
competencias que ya estaban programadas
en estos horarios o si los que son
durante el día se podrá tener un aforo
de hasta 5000 personas por lo tanto hoy
por hoy los únicos que tienen
garantizada su presencia por ejemplo en
la ceremonia inaugural son las entradas
de protocolo que va a repartir y que ya
ha repartido el comité olímpico
internacional los patrocinadores y
también las autoridades de los distintos
países que visiten por esos días la
capital nipona mire todos estos cambios
e incertidumbres sobre la realización de
los juegos tuvo un impacto en la
preparación de muchos atletas podría
verse afectado su rendimiento y la
calidad de los olímpicos si somos
ignorados hay todavía algunos
deportistas que no han podido
trasladarse en tiempo y forma a las
distintas escalas en donde tenían que
realizar su puesta a punto ideal para
llegar al comienzo de los juegos
olímpicos yo vivo en la argentina y hay
en este momento
restrictivas muy severas en la argentina
e impiden la entrada y la salida de las
personas solamente seiscientas personas
por día pueden movilizarse en los
distintos aeropuertos internacionales y
conozco de varios casos de deportistas
argentinos por ejemplo que ya deberían
estar o en europa o llegando a tokio por
estos días para realizar lo que es
lógicamente la aclimatación y la
diferencia horaria y todavía están
esperando ver cuando viajar y no tienen
fecha tampoco de viaje por lo tanto
seguramente estaremos en presencia de
unos juegos olímpicos que como todos
serán una fiesta pero que quizá no solo
vamos a tener que ser un poco menos
exigentes con respecto a los récords
olímpicos los récord mundiales porque se
va a realizar en circunstancias bastante
particular bueno mire estos juegos sin
duda alguna serán recordados históricos
o por todos los cambios y todas las
dificultades con las que se van a
realizar y finalmente tendremos un
cubrimiento periodístico también muy
agudo y muy complicado muchísimas
gracias juan jose por estar con nosotros
en france 24 y a nuestros televidentes
sigan con nosotros volvemos con más en
minutos
[Música]